Hello, hello, hello!
You’re watching SCP Explained, and today,
we’ve got an offer you simply can’t refuse:
The very latest in anomalous self-improvement
technology, which the SCP Foundation calls
SCP-212, but we much prefer to call The Improver.
Believe us when we say that this miraculous
device will change your life.
You’ll never be the same after a run-in
with The Improver.
It’ll make you fitter, healthier, better.
Not convinced?
Don’t worry - just sit back, and let us
sell you the dream!
Here’s some unpleasant news: You’re going
to die!
No matter how healthy you are right now, there
will inevitably come a day when your lungs
stop pumping, your ticker stops ticking, and
all those delightful little synapses in your
brain stop sending electrical and chemical
signals to and fro.
What a bummer!
Why would you want to be dead?
You can’t do stuff when you’re dead!
And it’s all because everyone is eventually
betrayed by the very things currently keeping
them alive: Those pesky, squishy, fallible
organs.
But thanks to The Improver, getting stuck
with the organs you were born with is a problem
of yesteryear.
No matter what those lousy Sarkicists tell
you, the flesh is unreliable.
Metal and plastic, on the other hand?
That’s built to last.
Bleeding hearts talk a lot about “Quality
of life”, but what really matters is “Quantity
of Life”, and if you’re strong enough,
that’s what The Improver - a state-of-the-art
piece of medical technology - will give you.
Don’t look so afraid.
You replace your phone every year.
You replace your laptop every few years.
So why get all sentimental about needing to
trade in your old liver, eyes, limbs, or skin
for the new model?
Or, in the words of another great businessman,
“Why be you when you can be new?”
Not convinced?
Let us tell you about the incredible features
that The Improver has to offer.
I’m talking three, top of the line fully
opposable, plastic and steel autonomous medical
limbs - that’s industry lingo for robot
arms that work on their own - with five hundred,
count ‘em, five hundred different attachments!
But I know what you’re thinking, “Five
hundred attachments?
Where am I gonna find the room for all that,
SCP Explained?”
To which we say, don’t worry about it!
Due to its spatially anomalous properties,
The Improver is able to store all these attachments
within its arms without any additional space
concerns.
And hey, I see that nervous look in your eye.
You’re worried about the operating costs,
right?
But don’t worry, there’s no need!
The Improver is completely self-powered, with
no discernable power source.
And you know this thing is safe because the
SCP Foundation has given it the “Safe”
object class.
Sure, that doesn’t technically mean it’s
not dangerous, but it does mean it won’t
sprout legs and walk off if you leave it to
its own devices, so you’re looking at a
long-term investment with a three-year warranty,
and an endorsement from the fabulous folks
at the Church of the Broken God.
You just can’t argue with these deals, my
friends!
We even offer competitive rates against Marshall,
Carter, and Dark!
But hey, we’re not trying to pull the wool
over your eyes here.
You’re a smart consumer.
We know that you know that the actual financial
cost is only one layer of the overall cost:
Time and training is also, of course, a factor.
But we’ve got some good news for you, sunshine
- The Improver is 100% user-friendly.
No setup, no mess, no problem.
No trying to interpret poorly written instructions
or watching padded-out YouTube tech tutorials
where the guy just will not get to the point,
The Improver operates itself.
It may be a piece of hyper-advanced anomalous
technology, but it’s easier to use than
most wireless printers!
The steps to using The Improver are so simple,
a monkey could do it: Just step within a 1.5-meter
range of the machine, and it will do the rest.
You’ll feel your troubles melt away as the
powerful mechanical arms grab you and restrain
you against the floor.
You’ll be subjected to a brief, relaxing
scan, where The Improver will determine exactly
what needs to be changed about your fragile
human physiology.
And then, before you know it, surgery will
commence!
Warning: SCP Explained is not liable for any
excruciating pain caused by The Improver.
Medical sedatives and anesthetics are sold
separately.
The consumer is responsible for their own
pain relief when using The Improver.
Second Warning: The consumer is also responsible
for their own blood transfusions when using
The Improver.
Neither The Improver nor SCP Explained is
liable for any blood lost while using The
Improver.
Your blood, your problem.
Now with those tiny little caveats out of
the way, we can carry on telling you just
how fantastic The Improver is.
Sure, flesh-worshipping Sarkicist losers and
haters will tell you that it has a mortality
rate of around 47%, but we prefer to look
on the bright side and focus on its excellent
53% survival rate.
Rest assured, the odds are still very much
in your favor when you use The Improver.
And doesn’t adding a slight risk to the
equation just make the whole process even
more exciting?
We certainly think it does!
And in the reasonably likely event that you
survive using The Improver, the benefits will
vastly outweigh the costs!
It can do incredible things - like lining
your joints with graphite, replacing your
nasty flesh organs with more powerful artificial
ones, adding new or duplicate organs, replacing
those unreliable teeth with serrated steel
bands, and so much more!
Is there anything this absolute marvel of
a machine can’t do?
Doctors hate it - The Improver is here to
fix every aspect of your life and health with
its simple anomalous tricks.
It even has a special sealant for wound-closing
that no medical professional on earth has
access to.
What is it, exactly?
Well, if we told you, I’m afraid we’d
have to kill you.
It’s a trade secret!
You’d have to be crazy to not want The Improver
in your home, but if, for some crazy reason,
you still need to be convinced, let’s look
at some real success stories of The Improver
in action - straight from SCP Foundation testing
logs!
Listen close and soon you’ll see, The Improver
literally makes satisfied customers!
The Foundation put a 28-year-old African-American
Agent into The Improver of his own volition.
It replaced his boring lower jawbone with
a super-dense ceramic jaw, with ceramic blades
instead of teeth.
It also removed his spine and replaced it
with a synthetic polymer, which was easily
affixed to the base of his skull.
And at no extra charge, it even coated his
rib cage and pelvis with a thin layer of ceramic,
before removing his lungs, eyes, and liver
for cleaning and replacement.
That’s right, cleaning!
The Improver can remove organs and, through
a patented cleaning process, remove genetic
defects and allow them to appear younger and
healthier than generic, Brand-X Organs.
This agent has since returned to active duty,
and is even better at his job, all thanks
to The Improver!
A 42-year-old British Foundation researcher
was submitted for testing on The Improver.
It replaced his teeth with sleek, super-dense
ceramic, reinstated his inefficient feet,
and replaced them with a complex latticework,
covered in sticky pads that would have let
him climb on any surface and hold up to 225kg
of weight.
It also took out and cleaned a huge number
of his organs, removed his bone marrow and
replaced it with blue synthetic gel - much
more effective, we assure you - and inserted
a few random bits of metal into his brain
at no extra cost.
Sadly, this researcher passed away during
the bone marrow removal process, but for all
we know, that could easily just be a coincidence.
Next came an Agent codenamed “A.A.”, who
had suffered a pretty severe accident at work,
losing all of his limbs, one of his eyes,
a few of his organs, and suffering a pretty
traumatic head injury - namely, taking a piece
of circuit board to the brain during an explosion.
He was given over to The Improver, seeing
as he didn’t really have much to lose in
terms of physical integrity.
But seeing that it’s an amazing piece of
groundbreaking technology, The Improver never
takes the obvious option.
It gave A.A. a chemical that forced him into
a coma, and then properly integrated the circuit
board into his brain
It continues to spread and assimilate more
of his brain matter while he’s in a comatose
state.
But when he awakens with a much more efficient
brain, he’ll probably be incredibly grateful
to The Improver for helping him like this.
And it’s not just people with severe injuries
that The Improver can lend three helping robotic
hands to, it’s also the victims of severe,
and even anomalous, diseases.
Take victims of SCP-217, a rather horrific
and painful disease that mechanizes the entire
body, until the sufferers aren’t really
themselves anymore.
A normal, uninspired SCP Foundation researcher
may look at someone like this and see a lost
cause, but with the help of The Improver,
no cause is lost!
A D-Class in the advanced stages of the disease
was run through the machine, and while the
exact details of what it did to him are another
trade secret, it’s safe to say he was truly
fighting fit when he came out on the other
side.
We mean that literally: He easily escaped
containment and overpowered two heavily armed
guards, before taking the lives of several
members of Foundation staff before being captured
and terminated sometime later.
You can’t argue with those incredible results,
folks.
Next came a 26-year-old SCP Foundation researcher,
who - due to an unfortunate brush with a less
wonderful and beneficial anomaly - had been
rendered completely blind.
However, when he was brought into the grasp
of The Improver, it immediately set to work
on solving the doctor’s little problem.
It removed his two non-functioning eyes and
made the interesting creative choice of widening
the two cavities in his head so they met in
the middle and formed one huge cavity for
a single large sensory organ.
This cavity was then filled with large metal
spikes resembling hair, which are far more
interesting than typical eyes.
During The Improver’s delicate medical procedures,
the scientist inexplicably entered a state
of visible distress, and began repeating the
phrase, “It tastes all wrong.”
At this point, the metal cilia in the scientist’s
single large eye cavity began to grow, extending
up through the roof of the cavity and into
the subject’s brain, killing him.
We want to specify that SCP Explained and
The Improver are in no way responsible for
this unfortunate incident.
It’s entirely the researcher’s fault for
setting off his own metal eye cavity cilia.
Before we bring this anomalous infomercial
to an end - and of course, before you immediately
grab your credit card to buy your own Improver
device - we want to sneak a few more disclaimers
under the wire.
For starters, The Improver doesn’t work
on animals.
When a rat was used as a test subject, the
device attempted to modify the rat into a
bipedal being, removing the majority of its
organs and replacing it with white paste.
So if your pet rat gets sick, just take it
to the vet instead.
The Improver also doesn’t work on corpses.
It may be a miraculous piece of technology,
but it’s not a literal miracle worker.
One freshly executed D-Class was presented
to The Improver, and instead of operating
on him, The Improver cut open his stomach
and instead began constructing something out
of the meal he had consumed the night prior
to his death: A seafood dinner.
The broken crustacean parts were then constructed
into a bioluminescent lobster-like creature.
So if you’re planning on bringing someone
back from the dead, we’re afraid you’re
going to need to take up necromancy instead.
But if you haven’t died yet, and you’re
looking to improve yourself, then you cannot
invest in a better product than The Improver.
The one problem is that the only known prototype
of The Improver is currently locked in an
SCP Foundation containment site, so getting
your hands on these three special arms may
cost you your life.
What?
Who said attaining perfection would be easy?
Now go check out “SCP-914 - The Clockworks”
and “SCP-001 - The Broken God - Ouroboros
Cycle” for more frightening anomalous machines!